combien de temps et combien de fois par
semaine faut-il courrières ça c'est
toujours la grande question car si vous
commencez la course à pied moi j'irai
qu'une fois par semaine pas largement
bien fait ça plusieurs semaines le temps
que votre corps comprennent qu'on va lui
demander de faire de l'activité physique
et surtout que ça va lui faire du bien
ensuite avec cette habitude quand vous
aurez moins de courbatures pour essayer
de passer si vous avez tant bien sûr à
deux fois par semaine deux fois trente
minutes deux fois quarante minutes deux
fois 45 minutes sur un rythme tranquille
jamais d'essoufflement toujours bien si
jamais vous avez des gènes vous
ralentissez vous marchez vous stoppez
pas vous marcher tranquillement
voilà pour le petit conseil et surtout
surtout jamais deux jours de suite
il faut le temps de la récupération la
récupération ça c'est une science du
sport
à bientôt pour prochain conseil